the United Nations is now pro in Tifa
how much more evidence do we need before
we finally defines the United Nations
this should be it you've got BLM
admitting that they're marxist how much
more evidence do you need before you
pull your support from BLM same thing
here with aunty Fay they tweet quote UN
hashtag Human Rights experts express
confound profound concern over a recent
statement by the US Attorney General
describing an Tifa and other anti
fascist activities as domestic
terrorists saying it undermines the
rights to freedom of expression and of
peaceful assembly in the country see how
they're conflating an taifa with
anti-fascists now auntie feh is a
communist anarchist terror group
anti-fascist just means you oppose
fascism let's take that example all the
way back to when fascism had any sort of
meaning which is back in World War two
with Mussolini and sort of with Hitler
though National Socialism is sort of a
different thing but lumping both
together fine that was the last time the
word fascism really meant anything
George Orwell wrote an essay about this
have after the Second World War the word
fascism lost all of its meaning but in
that war you see a lot of leftists these
days talking about the Allied troops as
the original anti-fascists remember
there were two kinds of anti-fascists in
World War two there were the Americans
and the British
our guys good guys and there were
Stalin's communists both anti-fascist
when you're just opposed to something
that leaves it wide open to
interpretation as to what side you are
actually on some anti fascists are good
right if you if you're an American
soldier in World War two that makes you
that's a good guy but if you're Stalin
just because you opposed Hitler at a
certain point doesn't make you a good
guy doesn't mean that I want to ally
with Stalin okay and yet the United
Nations conflates the - we need to
defund the United Nations we pay 22% of
the UN budget to invite the worst people
on earth
sit on a Human Rights Council some of
the worst most despotic regimes in
history sit on a human's Rights Council
then they fly to New York to the seat of
the United Nations and criticize the
United States and we like masochists pay
the bill we say thank you
Thank You Venezuela may I have another
thank you North Korea North Korea thank
you Cuba may I have another thank you
Iran may I have another why are we doing
that the UN is situated on beautiful
waterfront property we could knock down
that building we could bring in some
nice bulldozers we could create
beautiful Trump condominiums and we
would save a lot of money every single
year now is the time to do that we are
in a battle that has become ideological
it's not just in the u.s. it's
international but it's the same issues
what are we fighting for why are we why
are we paying people and tolerating
people destroying our nation our history
our culture
[Music]
you
[Music]